the first 10 amendments to the US
Constitution also known as the Bill of
Rights were ratified or passed over 200
years ago but even though they're a bit
well old these first 10 amendments are
still the most debated and discussed
section of our Constitution today so can
you remember what they are let's take a
look the first amendment is the freedom
of speech press religion assembly and
petition this may be the most revered of
the amendments the First Amendment
protects our rights to say and write our
opinions worship how we please assemble
together peacefully and petition our
government if we feel the need the
second amendment is the right to bear
arms the original intent of the Second
Amendment was to protect colonists from
the invading British soldiers but it now
guarantees that you have the right to
own a gun to defend yourself and your
property the third amendment is called
the quartering amendment it was written
in response to the British occupation
and as a result the colonists having the
house or quarter soldiers in their homes
during the American Revolution because
of this amendment our government can
never force us to house soldiers in our
home the fourth amendment is a right to
search and seizure the police can't come
into our home without a search warrant
and take our personal property today
many concerns have arisen about our
rights to privacy and technology for
example can the government track your
location with your smartphone or can
social media postings such as on
Facebook and Twitter be used without a
warrant on to the fifth it's all about
due process you've probably heard the
phrase I plead the fifth and movies are
on TV they're talking about the fifth
Amendment which says that you don't have
to take the witness stand against
yourself if you may end up incriminating
yourself okay or halfway done
the sixth and seventh amendments are
about how the legal system works if
you're accused of a crime you have the
right to a speedy public trial and an
impartial jury you also have the right
to a lawyer and the right to take the
stand if you choose this is important
because it will prevent the accused from
sitting in prison forever and insist
that the prosecution proceed
with undue delay the seven says you've
the right to a jury trial where twelve
impartial peers decide your innocence or
guilt in the courtroom as opposed to a
judge doing it all alone the Eighth
Amendment prohibits cruel and unusual
punishment is a death penalty cruel is
it unusual it's hard for Americans to
agree on the definitions of cruel and
unusual the 9th and 10th amendments are
called the non rights amendments they
say that the rights not listed in the
Bill of Rights are retained by the
people in the states you have other
rights that are not listed in the
Constitution and the states have the
right to make their own policies like
instituting state taxes so now you know
all 10 amendments can you remember them
all if not remember this the Bill of
Rights are crucial piece of American
history and those society is undergone
many changes these past 200 and some
years the interpretation application of
these amendments are as vital today as
they were when they were written
you